it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the stories
behind the headlines and for that we
turn to fox news contributor
raymond arroyo raymond you were just
down at the border
a few weeks ago now there are reports
that the biden administration is
poised to make the border crisis even
worse
what laura as you saw when i was at the
rio grande
witnessing hundreds of migrants being
brought
rafted stateside by the cartels agents
told me they had one great fear
that the biden administration would lift
title
42. now this is the public health law
that dude covet allowed border patrol to
turn back thousands of single adults
trying to enter the united states now
axios is reporting that
biden could remove title 42 by the end
of july
without this law in place laura
officials told me today
they're going to be overwhelmed they'll
have to release more than a hundred
thousand illegal aliens into the country
each month
potentially and what about the covet
considerations we want to vaccinate
students and sports stars
what about migrants well they'll get
free vaccines too we have so much extra
cash lying around there's everyone's
going to get free
by the way right now we still have
restrictions
in place raymond people from mexico
and canada they can't cross the border
legally right
right but the migrants could just pour
right in
i mean it's ridiculous we've closed the
border to legal mexicans and canadians
but hundreds of thousands you know
whatever a million almost have come
across
agents told me today of the 180
illegal immigrants that they encountered
a hundred and eighty thousand
they turned back a hundred and twelve
thousand
single largely men because of this title
forty two
with that out the window it's open
season and america becomes the season
uh laura some are indignant and
downright
silly in their coverage of the catholic
bishops efforts
to remind their flock of their
responsibilities in public
bishops are drafting a document on
worthiness to receive
communion basically the standards of
membership
here's how the media is covering it
catholic bishops here in america are
pushing to allow priests
to deny the president communion over his
support of abortion rights the president
made clear he's not planning to change
his routine
in the face of this debate among
american catholic bishops
this is so misinformed laura i don't
know where to begin first off
this bishop's document means nothing
canon law
church law requires priests and bishops
to refuse communion to anyone who
persists in
manifest public grave sin it's not an
option
the problem is the local bishops are
responsible they refuse to act
biden and is only one of many catholic
figures
opposing core moral teaching in public
this isn't private sin it's public
and it's teaching other catholics how to
behave
now that the bishops are having a
discussion media commentators are
beside themselves for
president biden who in that moment is
just joe biden going to his church and
taking that moment to honor
his beliefs that should not be
weaponized against him these bishops
could be working with him
on climate change i mean we're
destroying god's earth okay
and on the refugee crisis and what have
you and poverty in this country
instead they want to fight and so people
just see it as really
based in hypocrisy and i can't tell you
some people said you know this is the
final straw for them if the bishops
go ahead with that that's it for them
wait a second wait a second wait a
second
is that a priest was that a priest
yes father beck father he needs a
refresher in the catechism laura
i mean if truth in advertising and
insisting
that catholics behave like catholics in
public
is a bad thing well then they better go
find another faith i mean no one's
compelling you to be in any faith
but if you say you're one thing then be
it but thomas
aquinas yeah joy behar is in town move
over
saint augustine or thomas aquinas they
don't know anything listen to joy okay
but
before i go senator sheldon whitehouse
of rhode island i know a friend of yours
was cornered by a local reporter over
his membership in the bailey's beach
club
this is an exclusive very restricted
resort that he has enjoyed for decades
are there any minority members of the
club now i think the
people who are running the place are
still working on that i'm sorry it
hasn't happened yet
you had remarks on the floor following
the deaths of brianna taylor and
george floyd saying you know hoping to
root out systemic racism in the country
your thoughts on an elite all-white
wealthy club
again in this day and age you know
should these clubs continue to exist
it's a long tradition
in rhode island and there are many of
them
yeah clan meetings are traditions in
some parts of the country too laura
look this is over the line white house
tried to clean this up today by claiming
the club
does have diverse membership and that he
will no longer be a member
but remember laura his wife is the third
largest shareholder in the club so we
won't just
be there he'll share ownership hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else